ah Bratislava the city you know as that
place next to Vienna my name is Emma
laser let's get to it
the name Bratislava was given to the
city after World War one due to reasons
we are going to discuss later before
World War one the city was known by many
names and depending on who you ask the
name of the city and the etymology of
that name could be completely different
just to feel the names for the city are
Pazhani polonium fresh pork is
trophyless
or Pressburg the name is triple O's
comes from mostly Greek but also Latin
and it simply means Danube city the most
used name for the city throughout
history is presberg which is Austrian it
comes from an abbreviation of an old
version of the name breslov sport which
literally means castle brazo who was a
historic owner of the castle the Slavic
name for the city fresh product comes
from the name Pressburg which was
modified by the Slavic language however
Hungarian sources claim the cities named
paul-jean
which according to them was the name of
the owner of the castle or maybe it was
the name of the king st. Stephen's great
commander who fought in the war of
fresberg and therefore the city was
named after him they also claimed that
the names presberg and fresh Modoc are
just modified versions of name for
joining however it may also be that the
name for showing is visor such as major
iced version of the word presberg there
are many sources here that contradict
each other and therefore I'm just going
to call the city Bratislava so I knew
don't get a headache register delays on
an important strategic point in Central
Europe between the Carpathian Mountains
and the Alps on an important trade route
on the river Danube it is also no
coincidence that this strategical place
on the river Danube is also one of the
oldest continuously inhabited places in
Central Europe the first known human
settlement in the area was in the
Neolithic times however remnants of
Neanderthals and even earlier word I
can't pronounce were found around
Bratislava dating back between 25 to 15
million years ago the first time
fortified settlement in the area was
found under today's by the Sala castle
dating back to the a Neolithic era by
the end of the Bronze Age the settlement
shifted to nearby Devon where the river
Moravia joined a river Danube and during
the Iron Age shifted back to the Castle
Hill during the Iron Age at the end of
the second century BC a very important
Celtic city was constructed with a mint
and a fort on the castle hill this city
was a major Celtic trade center and
economically important to the area
however around the first century CE due
to continuous harassment by the Germanic
tribes the Celts had to flee the area
seeking refuge across the Danube
in the Roman Empire from first to fifth
century CE II without the Celts in the
area anymore Romans tried to expand
their power across the Danube for
setting up a small trade post and stupa
and then tried to build baths and
dubravka however due to internal
struggles and Germanic tribes most of
these attempts were unsuccessful in the
5th to 6th century during the migration
period Slavs arrived to the area and
created the basis for the ports we see
in the area today at the end of the 6th
century however the Eurasian avars came
and threatened the Slavic settlements in
these desperate times the Slavs in the
area rallied behind the skilled
merchants amo and with his help they
managed to drive out the avars and
establish a first Slavic political
entity around the region of Bratislava
Anitra sadly after Sawa's death the
kingdom fell apart from 8th century
until 907 resulallah castle as well as
devin castle were important centers of
principality of Nitra which was part of
the great Moravian Empire after the fall
of the Moravian Empire around 10th
century Breslaw came under the control
of the Hungarians is a precious lava a
strategic position and became a site of
frequent attacks and battles and
therefore the castle became one of the
best fortifications in Hungary along
with the city and a place of frequent
stay of Hungarian kings in the following
year spread to saw as a stage for
numerous and I mean countless of battles
during which the city changes hands
between hungarians to hree to hungarians
to bohemia to hungarians then pause for
the crusades during the witch in the
12th century warriors gather in
bratislava to start up the Third Crusade
and the 15th to 16th century the
hungarian kingdom declines and suffers
major losses to the ottomans during this
time the hungarian kingdom also fell
under the rule of the Hapsburgs
and the capital of Hungary was moved to
Bratislava where it for almost 300 years
the hubs works were crowned as the
hungarian kings this was the height of
precious aust power during which
expanded tremendously thanks to Austrian
immigrants and Hungarians filling the
Ottoman conquest as the seat of
Hungarian King versus I was the
administrative heartland of Hungary and
because of that grew in wealth power and
became the most populous city in Hungary
however in the 19th century when
Ottomans were defeated the capital of
Hungary changed back to Budapest and
this was the start of the downfall for
better slava after World War 1
Bratislava
at the time fresberg was at a crossroad
the city had a large diversity with
Austrians making up the majority of the
city's population but they were very
sizeable Slovak and Hungarian
populations in the city as well the city
tried to declare itself independent
Howard
in 1960 Lockean troops annexed the city
and declared it as the capital of
Slovakia renaming it from presberg to
Bratislava the name Bratislava came from
a poorly transcript script of the early
kings named Breslau or to check King who
is thought to have controlled the city
for a while the nasty slow nevertheless
the name stuck and presberg became known
as Bratislava ever since between a war
period where the saw was slowly starting
to turn around from its downfall how it
was a very slow change which was halted
by the start of world war ii during
world war ii brother saw was the capital
of the first slovak republic which was a
puppet state of nazi germany during this
time sad Janka khalid Aldus municipal
park in central europe was converted
into a ghetto / concentration camp for
fifteen thousand or so Jews living in
Bratislava after world war ii beretta
saga came under the control of the
communists during which it very slowly
rebuilt due to an effective communist
reform however in new area of the city
was built during this time at the
Schalke after the fall of communism and
the split of Czechoslovakia in 1993
brett Esau became the capital of the
Slovak Republic Bratislava now is the
seat of a corrupt government which had
overseen a very poor distribution of the
state's wealth after communism and is
accused of numerous money laundering
schemes nevertheless in the past few
years right - Slava underwent a large
expansion and hopefully remain strong
into the future
thank you for watching my video in
around five minutes where I tried to
explain the history over the city in
five minutes
suggest new cities down in the comments
section below or on the reddit post the
link in the description